this blinky dude is an Android and this
strange-looking orange is actually the
Sun eat it
Vsauce Kevin here this is Milo
the fact that this graffiti themed
commercial for the super Gameboy was
banned isn't nearly as cool as who did
the voiceovers and don't like nuke
dunkey goal-keeper table would come
proving once again that wu-tang Clan
ain't nothing too far whoa hey
what oh all right
wait what incredible if you're in a
hurry to eat dinner I guess you could
raise your dining table and if you're in
a hurry to save money just feed your
digital piggy bank it's like a virtual
pet that literally cries when it's
hungry
for credit cards earlier this month a
NASA scientist was like I found
extraterrestrial microbial life in a
meteorite and now a bunch of other
scientists are like
so instead they found a store that sells
Pringles and vodka and lived happily
ever after
you might have heard the fan audio remix
of Super Mario Brothers but check out
some more sound effect updates of
classics like Tetris contra and pac-man
motorcycles made completely from
wristwatch parts are cool but a homemade
pulse laser gun sounds like a great way
to destroy evil balloons or origami if
these little papers continue to fold
themselves and eventually rise up
against manhood wooden path too is a
puzzle game that you can play by
clicking the link below and this is a
mock-up for an underground mansion that
has an interesting feature but it's over
in the bedroom where things get really
exciting because over in the corner is a
slide for that early morning dip down
below in the heated swimming pool so it
raises the question what's the coolest
thing to have in your bedroom
finally here's an epic stop-motion
battle between Mega Man and some
transformers
I'm going to leave you with a riddle the
first person to get the riddle right and
explain how they got their answer will
be featured at the top of Vsauce is
channel page as our genius of the week a
man was found dead in his house with a
gun in his hand there was a tape
recorder on his desk when the police
arrived they pressed play on the tape
recorder and heard this is it my life is
over and then the sound of a gunshot how
did the detective immediately know that
it wasn't suicide and that the man was
murdered think you know it leave your
answer in the comments below and as
always thanks for watching
wait mind blow is not over yet find out
what this monkeys doing and info on real
cyborgs click here to watch FAQ where we
take something from mind blow and give
you the facts and knowledge about it
while you're there be sure to subscribe
to Vsauce 2